what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are gonna watch Wednesday episode
six today almost done with the series John
how does that make you feel I am filled with
whoa I'm not ready to let go how are you sir
I did not watch a bunch of Jenna Ortega interviews
last night what are you talking about anyway
guys listen you know what would help us out
right now if you guys can leave a like I know
you can't it doesn't cost you a dime but it
sure does help us out so please go ahead and
do that also subscribe click that notification
Bell get notified what our next reaction for
Wednesday is up here on the channel and as
always as we constantly mention full-length
Reaction watch along is where you sync up
with your own copy of Wednesday available
for super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page become a super sexy reject today to check
out all the exclusive shows that we cover
over there with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included alrighty on to this episode
foreign
I don't hold seances very often but my mother
told me goodie is the only one that can train
me to control my psychic ability she doesn't
really warned you about her sooner I cracked
this case
[Music] the most Tim Burton Ouija board
where's Enid
I was like she's gonna stop her here I was
reaching into the black maw death to contact
a relative and attempting to summon her but
she seems to be ignoring mind treaties you
thought about using one of my scented candles
the aroma of steak tartar is to die for oh
my meaty candle maybe good answer to you after
all I doubt she communicates in magazine cutouts
you don't know that
the game is afoot if you are Justice please
do not lie
foreign
you insisted on coming along I was fine on
my own don't be a pussycat why do I just stay
out here
look out you got the zenid you're the muscle
looks dangerous outside too
added a sound effect to her turning around
[Music]
sound effect does not match that's what all
flashlights sound like come on man
whoever you are show yourself [Music] try
anything and you'll lose limbs
oh surprise oh no [Music]
happy birthday to you how'd they know thing
oh happy birthday to you I should have known
you were behind this I thought my cake design
was pretty inspired the pink balloon was my
little touch why don't you make a wish come
on Wednesday Wish For answers fire will rain
when I Rise the first part of that phrase
was burned on a Nevermore song it can't be
a coincidence we never eaten that cake are
we cake would have to wait [Music]
nice hot headshot I was told you could teach
me how to control my ability there is no controlling
a raging River you must learn to navigate
it without drowning time is not on our side
they don't look exactly the same to me but
they are at the same actually yeah they must
do something to make her look more gaunt that
were Raven is a solitary one the balloon unable
to trust others only seeing the darkness within
them is that supposed to scare me it should
you have to be crazy not to be scared may
your 16th be a sour and misery felt as your
desire your ever doubting mother and father
the last thing to hide it before they left
on parents weekend
wow we're still accepting presents
oh what did you get her a bright pink Blazer
what is it exactly silly I signature colors
I have one too no twinsies wear them together
to class Lucas feels terrible about what happened
at the dance but he had nothing to do with
burning those words onto your lawn you don't
know that he does his community service here
and we forget it ever happened community service
here yes last night in the Crypt you had another
Vision didn't you what'd you see you said
I was ready to speak with you you still think
I'm the monster haven't rolled it out you
want my help you know where to find me Wednesday
Adams Falls in your court Wednesday that's
a friend [Laughter] the ball of playtonic
connection is in your court where'd you get
that the bracelet this woman in the next Booth
told me about this self-help app so he could
help me refocus my life Morning song
I wonder if there's a well-placed you in there
the more you listen to them the more they
think they're closing to you how do you know
I just do which is why I'm warning the Normie
idiot who ruined my killer dress with his
prank to not get sucked into Morning song
Lucas is acting like she's flirting with him
yeah I know then again he always acts that
way my parents always made sure my birthdays
were memorable
let's go perfect surprise [Music] oh cool
the perfect cake oh that's awesome someone's
gonna make that for real the perfect party
games oh she had a bunch of friends [Applause]
oh yes [Music] that is creepy I haven't seen
you since our session with your family which
was certainly one I won't forget I'll leave
you to it
who's goody
she's a very distant cousin sounds like she
doesn't see you for who you really are she
sees more than you know who are you therapist
I doubt a cold heartless person would be sitting
by her friend's bedside feeling some modicum
of guilt for his condition I didn't ask for
a free session consider it my birthday gift
one of my therapists have used that line kill
Eugene to prove your point do you feel guilty
now an old death certificate clusters
[Music] Laurel Gates if I asked you out to
a non-birthday song free dinner would that
be something you're interested in I have a
tight deadline God damn it term paper it's
about how whitewashing the sins of our past
will come back to kill us all thank you oh
timely oh okay did I do something I feel like
ever since the Raven you've kind of been ghosting
me I love that shot it's such a distance between
them now nah but ghosting is romantic in this
contest she got closer to you man pushes you
away now that burned onto the lawn at school
it's also etched on the wall inside crack
Stones correct all right well I'll make sure
I put out an APB in a dead pilgrim I figured
since you no longer have an old Vendetta to
obsess over you're free to solve some real
crime
I don't bury hatchets what a waste I sharpen
them nice your line Works a little shaky I
saw that in a vision do you recognize it
ooh good perspective work I pass it when I
go honey
happy birthday after the dance I just wanted
to forget about you but I couldn't so I started
painting and that's what came out all right
I can hear you up there playing
nice effect created Netflix I'll buy one [Music]
music of your soul Wednesday now you look
a little moved by that Wednesday Adams Wednesday
forgot this could you give it back to her
birthday gift from Enid aren't you your boyfriend
go definitely not no problem I was just leaving
anyway
until no Mr smiles take your advice
it's on the other wrist it's on my ankle most
people think I'll never amount to anything
and while we're being honest I haven't done
much to make them think differently why'd
you trash the dance I don't know guess I was
angry that my dad was humiliated on Outreach
day I pay back but then after we did it kind
of felt like crap I realized I needed to wipe
the board you know start over if that makes
any sense it's a lot of sense it's wise goody
showed me this house for a reason I need to
unlock its Secrets or die trying Wednesday
Adams Psychic Detective medium sure Simon
Baker will be here any moment or uh Patricia
Arquette I don't know
so you have something to do with that there
death I need a distraction I know just appear
we will be spooked
it's a long shot so I'm gonna have to lay
it out for you we'll do it over pie at the
weatherbane you are so quiet oh my God are
you gonna can't fear of this come on max
spooky
what their meaning
[Music] damn who hit him oh
jeez call 9-1-1 [Music]
what we do in the back of the mayor's SUV
I saw him coming out of the Gates mansion
Gates mansion the hell were you doing house
hunting when someone is run over on the way
to give the police key information it usually
means they were onto something and all signs
point to the Kate's family in that house how
they're all dead every last one and I don't
believe in ghosts maybe you should and I believe
in ghost series I've seen the crazy [__]
around the corner yeah you know what school
is nearby I draw the line after werewolves
and vampires as of now the school is on Full
lockdown and your off-campus privileges are
revoked until further notice it's fine she
barely goes to school anyway
are you all right I I can't imagine witnessing
something like that it was on my bucket list
[Laughter] no man chooses evil because it
is evil he only mistakes it for happiness
the good he seeks did she put you up to this
encourage me to pursue other interests no
but she will expel you if you continue to
defy her so you're only looking out for my
best interests always I think we're a lot
alike we aren't uh I already have a mother
and a therapist that's enough torture even
for me oh
I would like to know where you get your clothes
though she's just been pushing everyone away
this episode except for Xavier I've reconsidered
your offer the non-birthday dinner that's
great um pick me up at 7 get in loser we're
going mystery solving steer clear Wednesday
Adam she's kind of girl is going to get you
hurt leave me another type is that supposed
to be about Mom of course not and that would
require you to actually talk about her I can't
deal with this right now oh of course not
close did you ever even love her every scene
window is about Mom we gotta talk about Mom
but we're not gonna talk about mom if only
there were a way for us to get off campus
and have a little birthday redo two best friends
too bad the school is on lockdown what how
about I say I'm about to Wolf out and get
a pass to the Lupine cages and so you volunteered
to lock me in my deviousness has finally rubbed
off on you what a great idea
I want that Rubik's Cube I gotta be a million
on Etsy right now [Music]
well done here for my date he's our Uber driver
Uber driver I thought we were going on a date
I thought this was a girls night out just
been a change of plans okay what's up with
the weird matching hoodie scarf things don't
ask it's a snood man
what does she think she's on her table Tyler
I want to do this and you should have just
said so you didn't have to trick us if you
want to go you can are you totally manipulated
them
let me try
[Laughter]
it's pointless can I try yeah
hey you're not such a late bloomer after all
extra werewolf strength the caddy oh my God
the car that hit the mayor dark turn to just
now well someone's clearly occupying it
thing would really come in handy right about
now
thing is not necessary [Music]
worshipers blood will rain blood will rain
[Music] one of those was freshly extinguished
crack Stone will return you're still warm
all right Tyler you check the rest of the
ground floor in a deny will search upstairs
I don't think you guys should split up [Music]
let's go time Tyler Hulk out come on his eyes
look like the Monster's eyes yeah Wednesday
we need to see this
look how clean this room is that's me no duster
cobwebs
I was gonna say is the doctor like secretly
their daughter ah
ah
okay looks like somebody moved back into their
old room she died 25 years ago drowned overseas
[Music] a likely story [Music]
[Music]
it's actually kind of scary yeah
gotta get this thing moving
some strong wool
oh yikes
I might have left is some important information
actually yeah what is this the family morgue
kind of the foot hey
the half of head where are those extra toes
[Music]
[Music] ooh this is exciting evidence
where was Tyler this whole time you know he
shouted
[Music]
where'd you come from uh I'm just here for
a mislead oh my God is the therapist the monster
no I will you cannot believe her now
I will I will go down swinging die on this
hill I'm okay Sheriff I understand you're
upset but I think you need to see something
that's all taken away damn it comes in handy
oh it's all gone now somebody cleared this
place out after we left today I told you signs
pointed to this to this right is that your
justification for almost getting my son and
your friends killed you're my new Grudge on
Wednesday yeah you are forbidden from seeing
Tyler and you are forbidden from pursuing
anything to do with this case understood give
me your gun and your badge you're directly
violated my explicit order and left Compass
during a lockdown I think Contrition might
be an order right now miss Adams not hubris
I'll never apologize for trying to uncover
a truth as well you shouldn't what is this
it's a warning from Rowan is this why he tried
to kill you his mother drew it before she
died said I was destined to destroy the school
well then we have to kill you Wednesday now
you know what's at stake everything you've
had to protect no less I think I deserve another
chance [Music] please Wednesday the hero one
more step out of line and you will be expelled
no ifs or no buts Enid and save your spirit
as well no more negotiation she's not Morticia
it's more like Gomez where are you going yoko's
room Thornhill said I can't crash there for
a few nights oh tonight was just the icing
on the birthday cake you couldn't even be
bothered to cut you will use anyone to get
what you want even if it means putting them
in danger we could have died tonight because
of your stupid Obsession but we didn't
Dart Detective always put myself out there
thought of your feelings told people I know
she gives off serial killer Vibes but she's
really just shy I never asked you to do that
you didn't have to because that's what friends
do you want to be alone Wednesday be alone
Dark Night of the soul and accompanying Thunderclap
a gnawing feeling [Music] foreign
watching me
[Music]
oh [__] damn
oh my God I found someone's Pi pics we all
seem to be connected like a spider's web and
when mayor Walker got too close to the truth
he was silenced
no Take that Mary Shelley
[Music] I will find you badass and I will
kill you great transition ah we're back to
form yes yeah absolutely we're back to the
momentum that was great that was that was
great
will not sway It's gotta be Tyler it has to
be but her eyes he's got his hairdo in the
eyes of the therapist look like the uh more
of the eyes of the monster it's fair it could
be that's a really good theory that you brought
up but now I'm gonna stick to that I'm gonna
make sure to cut it out of the reaction yes
please yeah I deserve that I'm not gonna let
you get the credit for that don't worry don't
worry it'll only last for now when it turns
out to be Tyler then you can rub it in my
face that's that's a really good theory that
it's that it's Laurel what was her name Laurel
Gates canbot or oh yeah or yeah Laura Laura
Gates Laura Gates is uh the therapist really
I mean that I could certainly see I feel like
that there they they did a thing with the
roses and it like the first when she's in
the hospital room they pause on the roses
and like some about those Roses and then uh
they're the same color at least and kind of
withery style that they find in the bedroom
yes I don't know yes maybe we're both right
about different things idea of a good mystery
supposed to throw you off to make you doubt
your suspicions sure and whenever I do that
and if I sway from it I'm like I should have
stuck to my guns I mean would it be too much
though if she's both Laurel Gades and the
monster but why would Tyler the monster why
would he have the scratches unless he's doing
like like I gotta cover this up or something
like like the way that series under this yes
we will use that yeah yeah yeah because it's
like he calls from downstairs to warn them
that he's about to Hulk out we don't know
why he hulks out or what causes it and then
yeah as he's turning back he's like okay I
gotta do a quick Rippy I could see that although
I'm also like what does he do with his clothes
because he's not wearing all of his full outfit
when he hulks out so then did he like put
his shirt back on and did he have like a remaining
claw to go or did he just find something else
to cut himself up with I don't know Sam can
be said for Xavier sure definitely not Xavier
it's not it's not Xavier you weren't misled
by that mislead about Xavier showing up just
at the right time can't be uh nah nah I can't
be man is too well motivated by thing so
yeah I think I don't know stick to your guns
G stick to your guns and this will stick into
this will be the exceptions I think you're
right though about Laurel gay that sounds
like a very solid Theory that sounds remarkably
solid yeah okay okay well both got a hill
to die on skill declaring this since the first
episode yeah your Hill is much bigger I will
die on an adjacent Mound I gotta stick to
it um well the first uh yeah I thought I thought
this was a really I just left the I love the
vibe of this episode it was so dark it felt
so noir-ish and but still like No warish And
Gothic at the same time it had a great blend
of both and this is my favorite of the mystery
angle of this whole season like the mystery
of foot and trying to solve it and then it
was the most intense it's ever gotten like
that was really when the monster was coming
in and the way they it felt like an actual
monster as this show has had like a monster
here and creatures there and that was the
first sequence that felt like a monster movie
yeah and so it was incredibly effective and
it was suspenseful and it was exciting like
it was a fun perilous like like a family-friendly
version of those perilous monster movies and
I really enjoyed the vibe of that and uh it
felt most in some ways this show kind of feels
like uh if Adam's Family took place in a world
that was like Hogwarts meet stranger things
and yeah I think that was a big vibe that
I had there the whole time which is like a
lot of that stranger things spooky Vibe uh
throughout and also the enhancement of the
because the last episode would have you sort
of believe that Wednesday was on a path to
you know opening up being more vulnerable
connecting but it seems that she has now closed
herself off even more which in a lot of ways
is more human once you get to that path of
oh I'm starting to connect I'm sorry now you
retreat but obviously that is supported by
the the oh so if I'm forgetting exactly what
goody Adams told her at the beginning other
than the fact that she's destined to be alone
and I feel like that plays a fact in her emotional
motives this episode she said some other [__]
yeah I don't remember what she said yeah about
the path of the Raven it was a lot about the
path of the Raven and all that and that had
to do with her Visions damn because yeah there's
like so much happening and it is like so early
on in the episode and two I was just getting
lost in like the nuances of like oh I like
the subtle accent she does and things like
that but but yeah I mean she's at least leading
her to the truth that's at the gates house
she gives her that that clue basically the
Gates house is where you need to go well yeah
I thought this was a really I thought and
I thought it enhanced a lot of the the supernatural
Aura and the Mystery Aura um like the The
Ether of it was quite powerful both throughout
and uh like this is mainly like a nighttime
episode
and very investigative so yeah I enjoyed this
one a lot this was great like this was uh
back to the momentum that I was hoping the
show would pick back up again and it did after
one episode so yeah yeah love it now Sheriff's
son's gonna have a massive Vendetta next episode
he's gonna have a whole character re-change
he's gonna not smile anymore it was insanely
manipulative what she did it truly yeah it's
very very manipulative yeah yeah absolutely
I would be mad but I like I like the characters
of of like I'm gonna do whatever it takes
to get Justice and nothing will get in my
way or do the right thing to be the hero and
but it's like costing her so much and she
doesn't realize how much like they've they've
morphed her into a detective yeah that's her
character she is she is like an award detective
Wednesday at a private eye like I don't care
about people but she really does and um it's
bothered by that and it's fine so I think
it's a really good balance of it yeah it's
the hidden duality of like yeah you want to
solve the mystery and take down the evil but
why are you doing that you're also doing that
because there are people who don't deserve
to be subject to that and some of whom you
can now point to is like yeah these are people
that I would want to save from Peril even
if it's not at the Forefront of why she's
doing all this it's in there yeah yeah yeah
yeah and and yeah just like nobody's weight
like even in even characters who show up briefly
like nobody's wasted like that scene on the
staircase with Gwendolyn Christie's like the
one principal Weems major scene and like I
thought that was great like it's just the
way that they orchestrated everything and
like you know these well-worn tropes of like
you know oh you can't sneak out after dark
and of course that's exactly what we got to
do but yeah I thought they they had like the
perfect blend of tension and fun and then
when the actual like scary stuff starts to
happen like it lulls you into focusing so
much on the clues that that stuff does kind
of burst in and take you by surprise and it
doesn't seem villainous good one Gwendolyn
Christy I'm yeah I'm really curious because
yeah like at the outset you are so kind of
there are various reasons where on the surface
you would just imagine that she is like directly
a villain of some sort and I feel like there's
a they might do something interesting where
it is yeah like she is certainly willing to
go to extreme lengths to protect the greater
good but I think that's a more fitting Nuance
of the hero now is yeah evildoers don't necessarily
think they're doing evil obviously and yeah
principal Weems is in a weird position so
I could see how she could come out of this
as a very gray character with maybe that I
hate you but damn it I respect you kind of
vibe at the end and and that's the thing is
because you have the Tyler debate about whether
or not he'll be the monster I feel like there
are they've done well to cast so many other
shadows and so many other little Mysteries
that even if certain things read a little
bit obvious it it's doesn't take any of the
Wind out of the sale for me because there
are things like that where I'm like I don't
know I don't know I feel like principal Williams
could have easily been behind the wheel of
the Cadillac maybe she is involved at the
gates house or maybe she is as she appears
and that whole like that scene where she tells
Wednesday she cops two impersonating um uh
Rowan I was like I kind of bought that in
the moment which is a good mislead if it's
a mislead but she was like yeah you know we
didn't want to you know tarnish his memory
we didn't want to bring any heat to the school
I was like sure I buy that so I could see
her turning out not totally terrible the whole
thing I don't know other than a good job they've
done a really good job here yeah and just
when Sheriff Hopper and her were signing it
along I was about to adopt a letter God damn
it it's okay yeah I was gonna say now we gotta
figure out which stranger things kid every
character is and they all wanted to they try
to throw her birthday party I know and even
Ajax and a few other people showed no there
were people who showed up who I didn't think
would give your [__] to show up I didn't
realize it was a friendship five or six people
are here that's all you guys kind of gave
[__] about her that's kind of funny yeah
and even Bianca wasn't completely like you
know she could have easily been very [__]
about bringing this nude back but she was
just like yeah sure I'll bring it back I know
they Justified their relationship her and
Lucas but I don't still fully buy it um yeah
I'm curious I find Luke is charming but he's
just all smiles up until this point and I
feel like uh I I don't know I like I like
the idea of the character I am enjoying watching
him but I'm not fully I get where they landed
and why they landed there I guess it was what
started up that engine that I didn't quite
buy like their first scene together like what
is happening here like this I'm not buying
this scene I bought the latter scene more
but the first scene of what got them there
that that emotionally I don't know I I again
I guess it has something to do with the fact
that he had the brakes didn't want her to
protect him or something is that the first
real conversation they've had that is right
because I know you know I mean post post the
dance does he do they talk at all today I'm
trying to think like it it might have I don't
remember significantly any major not that
it had to be like a huge scene but like a
a thing setting up that they might have some
kind of Rapport to build on in the future
or some kind of knowledge of each other other
than like oh yeah you're the sheriff's son
and oh yeah you go to Nevermore um so yeah
I feel like that could have maybe been fleshed
by that orb if they're both black actors they're
both black actors it's true they have to have
a connection like pair them up yep Oh you
mean that's why they do things no I yeah I
mean maybe if he again I don't want to slag
the performance because I do find it Charming
but maybe if there had been in that scene
a little bit more like he's just so charming
and so kind of like even when he's doing the
prank because he's auditioning the whole time
I like Bianca a lot I just like I think I
feel like he's auditioning a lot I feel like
he's auditioning a lot and there's something
about his attitude that I just don't a hundred
percent feel the commitment to I liked it
in the later scene where he's like yeah I
don't really know why I did it uh even and
and extrapolating on that but in the moment
when he's being a bully I'm like I don't really
believe this guy's an actual bully like he
just happens to kind of be plopped here among
these other characters who do seem like actual
bullies and even though there are themes you
can draw about like yeah that's not who he
is he's being drawn into this lifestyle it's
not really well supported by the characterization
thus far yes but uh we'll see he'll turn into
something very significant
all right let it play out a player all right
guys what did you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below what's your
favorite Jenna Ortega interview tell us tell
us tell us tell us you can leave a like subscribe
and let's send this for the patreon
Ricardo Martinez Adams Family you know they
got some some Latin roots so I figure this
would be the perfect time to shout you out
I wonder if you're a spooky one in episode
seven uh you know because uh that's all right
dude I got a very big reason as to why it's
not episode seven I'm sorry I I would have
saved you for that but I got big plans all
right big plans to sit in motion Ricardo Martinez
in fact if you want to get on the ground floor
hit me up we'll discuss it and then you can
be part of my master plan I will use you much
like Wednesday used her friends in this episode
for my own personal gain and the gain of the
greater good of the patreon but at your expense
Ricardo so for the meantime until that happens
I hope you're having a good 2023 and uh thank
you for remaining with us through all these
wild and crazy shout outs we love you and
we appreciate you and we'll see you next time
much love
share away it's all episode stuff I should
have waited I'm sorry Ricardo don't don't
play it [Music]